yeah you said that you felt pressure
today and it's me it was very important
game so finally you reached your goal
this is the next one as you told me a
few few days ago now we have to win the
tournament how does it feel I mean all
this well I I actually remember last
year because uh last year Ali RZA came
he won the rapid and Blitz he won the
singfield cup and he won the grand chest
tour and I remember thinking this is
amazing to like I can't ever dream of
doing this and this year somehow I
managed to do exactly what he did last
he insired you you
it well I couldn't can't even say
inspired because I couldn't even expect
that I would be able to reach this these
Heights but uh um yeah somehow it all
worked out perfectly